I am not going to do a full segment on
part two of the Elon Musk Tucker Carlson
interview yesterday we looked at part
one and we looked at a bunch of it there
are two clips that I am compelled to
play for you though
oh this was a sec this is so weird Elon
and Tucker
talked about
the urge to impregnate women
as the interview really took a strange
turn listen to this I mean the urge to
have sex and to procreate is after
breathing and eating the most basic urge
how has it been subverted
well it's just the in the past we could
rely upon
um you know simple uh limbic system
rewards in order to procreate um but
once you have birth control and you know
uh abortions and whatnot now now you now
you can still satisfied Olympic Instinct
but not procreate
um so we didn't we haven't yet evolved
to
deal with that because this is all
fairly recent in the last 50 years or so
um for birth control you know I'm sort
of worried that hey civilization you
know if we don't make enough people to
at least sustain our numbers perhaps
increase a little bit then civilization
is going to crumble this is actually I
mean this is like wacky stuff and you
can tell from the look on Tucker
Carlson's face that it's not even clear
he really knows the direction this is
going there's a couple interesting
things here because on the one hand what
Elon Musk is saying is quite reminiscent
of extreme right-wing strict father
morality ideology when it comes to birth
control and one of the things that some
on the right don't like about birth
control you know you you do hear some of
them say Well it kind of goes against
the Bible you're not supposed to it's a
I I don't even know which parts of
scripture but there's some religious
claims that birth control violates the
Bible but for a lot of these right
Wingers
and again I don't think Elon Musk is a
right winger on so many different issues
but he's delving here into a view that
is very very prominent on the right wing
the opposition to birth control
isn't so much religious it's that you
shouldn't be able to engage in what they
call non-procreative sex and not have
consequences you should suffer the
strict father that's why we call the
strict father morality would say if
you're going to engage in sexual
intercourse there should be the
consequences of a pregnancy and if there
is you should be forced to carry the
baby to the the baby to turn
so he's kind of falling into that like
we it's it's dangerous that we've
separated the limbic response from the
procreation and now we have a low birth
rate he's kind of toying with that same
stuff and then there's the low birth
rate thing which has become a focus for
for Elon Musk question of like uh will
civilization end with a bang or a
whimper well it's currently trying to
end with a whimper in adult diapers yes
uh which is depressing as hell
the most depressing I mean seriously
yeah war is less depressing yeah it's
really caught with a bang yeah put your
shoes on yeah not with your door
exciting there you go so Tucker Carlson
visibly sucking up to Elon Musk
throughout the entire interview all
right they did also talk about
um uh the topic of aliens which was an
interesting moment yeah
um a lot of people ask me you know
um where are the aliens and I I think if
anyone would know about aliens on Earth
it would probably be me I would think
yeah I'm like you know very familiar
with space so yeah
um
and I've seen no evidence of aliens so
here you go I would immediately tweet
yeah tweet it out that says Split Second
and be like I'll be like all time
probably the top period of all time I
found one guys
it's a jackpot 8 billion likes you know
um Next Level jackpot if you find it
there you go so big reward on Twitter
for whoever announces proof of aliens
and every every aspect of this interview
very very strange and this will
certainly help to endear Elon Musk
further with the right-wing Community
given the hero's welcome by Tucker
Carlson let's call this long two night
nightmare of the Elon Tucker interview
over and we can move on from there one
of the best ways to support this show is
by supporting our sponsors today one of
those sponsors is sheath underwear it is
spring temperatures are rising many of
us know all too well about the sweating
and the sticking and the chafing but
that's only when you use traditional
underwear when you use sheath underwear
it's no longer a problem sheath
underwear is ergonomically designed with
separate compartments in the front to
keep everything dry cool and separate
and to keep you comfortable they come in
a zillion different designs something
for everybody the quality is amazing
super long lasting put an end to the
readjusting and the sweating and the
shifting uncomfortably sheath underwear
is really a lifesaver you will thank
yourself it's a unique product you've
got to try at least once to see for
yourself and my audience gets 20 off
with Pacman go to
sheathunderwear.com slash Pacman the
link is down below